half of all Americans have at least one
risk factor for heart disease Kirsten
Joyce connected with a cardiologist who
has tips to help better protect your
heart
disease Remains the number one killer of
all Americans cardiologist Elizabeth
clotis says it has killed more Americans
every single year than all cancers and
respiratory diseases combined and for
women it is by far our number one cause
of death just to put things in context
one out of 30 women will die from breast
cancer one out of three will die from
heart disease the CDC says 80 percent of
strokes and heart attacks are
preventable clota says it comes down to
Lifestyle if you smoke quit get active
she says nutrition is by far the most
impactful thing you can change diet
affects multiple risk factors high
cholesterol high blood pressure high
blood sugar diabetes excess weight poor
nutrition that's five major risk factors
for for heart disease and all five are
driven in part or On Hold by food she
adds high cholesterol is caused by a
deficiency of the right Foods step one
shouldn't be the throw pills at it step
one should be change the food
incorporate whole food ingredients with
fiber foods high in antioxidants and
ones that contain omega-3 fatty acids
for more tips on how to improve your
heart health reduce your medications and
manage high blood pressure go to our
website at 8newsnow.com